since when does spider-man have a thing
for curing evil and just getting into
college really such a big deal for one
of the world's most famous heroes these
questions and more are the kinds of
things in spider-man no way home that
only adults will notice
in spider-man no way home we pick up
right where the last movie left off with
mysterio revealing spider-man's identity
as 17 year old high schooler peter
parker with so much pressure from the
press police and the public peter finds
his world appended luckily he is cleared
of all charges but spider-man and his
best friends mj and ned are rejected
from mit due to their association with
peter parker it's a crushing blow for
peter that causes him to seek out dr
strange's help and set the plot of the
whole movie in motion but the more
seasoned members of the audience might
ask who cares for one thing mit's
reluctance to admit peter parker and his
friends is kind of unrealistic and also
the older you get the more you realize
how overblown the importance of college
is sure higher education is nice and all
and it can get you a leg up in life but
is it really worth risking the entire
universe over as the most famous person
in the world as well as a certified
genius who's helped save the world peter
could have easily got into business with
his equally brilliant friends hired
world-class tutors or found independent
funding based on his web serum alone
college only gets you so far being
spider-man is more than enough to get
peter to mit and beyond let's face it
you don't go to a spider-man movie to
have a long think about moral relativism
you go for the action and if you're
lucky a little bit of heart in this
movie a bunch of proven bad guys from
other universes get sucked into the mcu
and instead of kicking their butts back
to where they came from peter parker
decides to convince them to change their
wicked ways instead what why should we
be rooting for this the idea that
spider-man is too good of a guy to let
any harm come to his enemies is kind of
childish not to mention a little
contradictory with movies we've already
seen activate instant kill it's
established in no way home that the
presence of these villains threatens
peter's universe and the villains also
pose a real danger to everyone around
them and it sort of undercuts our years
of experience watching this spider-man
and others battle various villains to
the death when apparently they could
have just done some vague science stuff
and cured them all along you deserve
that i got ice cream you deserve that
you're a criminal bye mr criminal by far
the most fun part of no way home is a
hilarious stuttering interplay between
the three versions of spider-man all of
which appear to have aged along with the
actors that play their characters toby
maguire's peter has mellowed into early
middle age andrew garfield's beater is
dealing with the more existential onset
of your 30s and some holland's pizza
needs to help to deal with some late
teenage rage as they work on scientific
villain cures and plan the big battle
together there are enough laughs to fill
a whole sitcom older moviegoers also saw
a bit of themselves when garfield and
maguire's peter parker bonded over back
pain back pain happens to pretty much
everybody and it's oddly comforting to
see two iterations of spider-man himself
complain about middle back stuff it's
enough to make a person grateful that
their biggest issue is finding the right
standing desk or making time for a yoga
class and not constantly sustaining body
blows from a super powered rogue's
gallery
you don't have to have seen every
previous spider-man movie to enjoy
spider-man no way home but for each
movie that you haven't seen or don't
remember well there's definitely going
to be a few things you'll miss this is
an addition to the many mcu movies that
no way home assumes you've already seen
you need that background to understand
the dynamic between peter and doctor
strange and so on but taken as a whole
it's a lot to ask of the average viewer
at this point how many people who saw
the amazing spider-man 2 will remember
the finer points of the history between
electro and andrew garfield's spider-man
and after 14 years we might need a
little more than a line or two's worth
of refresher on what sandman's whole
deal with his daughter was in spider-man
3. obviously the mcu was built on a new
strategy of connecting the movies in a
larger universe and this worked a great
effect but each installment still has to
serve as its own story no way home
depends almost entirely on your
knowledge of other movies to a dizzying
extent kids who have been keeping up
will have a blast but any adult who's
been on enough spider-man will have a
seriously hard time keeping up with the
subtext of what's even happening it's
one thing for movies to bank on your
nostalgia but it's another thing to make
a viewer feel left out like they haven't
done their homework if you're a viewer
who's getting older and maybe started to
check out of comic book movies
spider-man no way home is like expert
level nostalgia designed to challenge
your memory of about a dozen movies from
decades past so you know too
it's cool um i mean i've known first and
i'm no longer but it's not a competition
if there's one crime the mcu has
committed it's the popularizing of mid
and post credit scenes after four phases
and two dozen movies marvel studios has
us trained on mass to wait through all
the credits for one or two more glimpses
of what the future instalments and the
series have to offer spider-man no way
home has a mid-credits scene with a fun
cameo that's worth the wait but that
makes you wait all the way until the end
for a teaser trailer for doctor strange
and the multiverse of madness it's not
even a post-credits scene called footage
or not it's just an advertisement even
by the logic of the mcu it seems
criminal to make people wait until the
very end of no way home to see a trailer
for a movie that they'll definitely see
anyway i'm gonna go thanks so much
everyone for coming check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about spider-man are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]